hi there its senior editor Kevin Van Ord
standing in for reviewer Lafe Johnson to
tell you about consortium okay someone's
a little eager consortium is a lot like
Mass Effect's if it were stripped of all
that business of exploring worlds and
drilling planets here events unfold in
an aircraft from 2040 to that feels like
the Normandy and looks strikingly
similar to a Boeing 747 but this isn't
some soulless ripoff look past some
tough bugs and visual oddities such as
the ugly dated faces and you'll actually
find a worthy role-playing game okay
then I believe consortium is populated
with a motley selection of nationalities
and races that work for a peacekeeping
organization that may or may not have
sinister intentions the entire concept
hinges on a military hierarchy that
labels people with the names of various
chess pieces but upon 12 David Benedict
at your service you for instance take on
the role of Bishop six warrior enforcer
of sorts on his first day on the job but
before your first day as the plot
reveals it's a fun job and you end up
investigating murders sniffing out
traitors and attempting to tame
mercenaries with diplomatic skills this
is very good
one of consortiums most fascinating
works is that it acknowledges you the
player as participating in a
satellite-based game that lets you slip
into the minds of figures from alternate
futures that might sound a little bit
like Assassin's Creed setup but only
minutes in consortium lets you blurt out
the truth if you wish part of what makes
consortium so appealing is that this
story element affects the various
mysteries and events push things too far
and the talking chess pieces around you
might start to doubt your ability to
lead them to checkmate are we done here
Bishop please guys
yeah the crew numbers sound far more
human than their antiquated models would
suggest conversations flow well from one
to another regardless of shifts in
subject matter and consortium tops it
all off with a generally competent voice
cast hey six are you ready to meet with
the Queen you spend almost all your time
with these folks on the ship so it's
good that the three decks offer plenty
of exploration to make up for the
absence of any ground exploration partly
thanks to the inclusion of a sweeping
musical score the mere act of exploring
air ducts is of pleasure in and of
itself
Consortium includes a shooter element
though you can usually avoid gunplay by
focusing on careful answers and juggling
the dispositions of various enemies and
friends in fact shooting is so secondary
that much of it occurs in training
exercises in a holodeck of sorts or
through a brief virtual dogfighting
sequence there are no specializations or
skills to tinker with only a smattering
of weapons and the ability to
incapacitate down soldiers or to heal
allies around you but be warned
consortium is a glitchy you might think
the game refuses to load only to
discover that it takes 5 minutes or so
for the main screen to appear and
there's an otherwise impressive sequence
late in the game that can cause all
manner of problems so many problems in
fact that the developer had to provide
players a workaround just so that they
could see the games ending that's too
bad because consortium delivers a
uniquely enjoyable RPG experience
despite its rather disappointing running
time around 4 to 5 hours for now though
it's best to wait consortium has a
fascinating story to tell that leads you
down some bizarre narrative pathways to
break the fourth wall considering that
this is partially a game about time
travel waiting a couple of weeks for the
upcoming patch plan to whip the game
into shape isn't that long to hold out
what do you say
will you surrender peacefully to me
[Music]